dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir do you
see this new table tennis robot it
barely played any games in the real
world yet it can return the ball more
than a hundred times without failing wow
so how is this even possible well this
is a seem to real paper which means that
first the robot starts learning in the
simulation openai did this earlier by
teaching the robot hand in a simulated
environment to manipulate this Ruby Cube
and Tesla also trains its cars in a
computer simulation why well in the real
world some things are possible but in a
simulated World anything is possible yes
even this and the self-driving car can
safely train in this environment and
when it is ready it can be safely
brought into the real world how cool is
that now how do we apply this concept to
Table Tennis
well in this case the robot would not
move but it would play a computer game
in its head if you will but not so fast
that is impossible what are we
simulating exactly the machine doesn't
even know how humans play there is no
one to play against now check this out
to solve this first the robot asks for
some human data look it won't do
anything it just observes how we play
and it only requires these short
sequences and then it builds a model of
how we play and embeds us into a
computer simulation where it plays
against us over and over again without
any real physical movement it is
training the brain if you will and now
comes the key step this knowledge from
the computer simulation is now
transferred to the real robot and now
let's see if this computer game
knowledge really translates to the real
world so can it return this ball it can
well kind of one more time
okay better and now well it missed again
I see some signs of learning here but
this is not great so is that it so much
for learning in a simulation and
bringing this knowledge into the real
world right well do not despair because
there is still hope what can we do well
now it knows how it failed and how it
interacted with the human yes that is
great why because it can feed this new
knowledge back into the simulation the
simulation can now be fired up once
again and with all this knowledge it can
repeat until the simulation starts
looking very similar to the real world
that is where the real fun begins why
well check this out this is the previous
version of this technique and as you see
this does not play well so how about the
new method now hold on to your papers
and Marvel at this rally
82 hits and not one mistake this is so
much better wow this seem to real
concept really works and wait a minute
we are experienced fellow Scholars here
so we have a question if the training
set was built from data when it played
against this human being does it really
know how to play against only this
person or did it obtain more general
knowledge and can it play with others
well let's have a look the robot hasn't
played this person before and let's see
how the previous technique fares well
that was not a long rally and neither is
this one and now let's see the new
method
oh my this is so much better it learns
much more general information from the
very limited human data it was given so
it can play really well with all kinds
of players of different skill levels
here you see a selection of them and all
this from learning in a computer game
with just a tiny bit of human behavioral
data and it can even perform a rally of
over a hundred hits what a time to be
alive so does this get your mind going
what would you use this seem to real
concept for let me know in the comments
below if you are looking for inexpensive
Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now offers the
best prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with Lambda GPU Cloud you can
get on demand and a100 instances for
1.10 per hour versus 4.10 per hour with
AWS that's 73 savings did I mention they
also offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and Caltech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers to
sign up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time